ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
42 38 32 28
28 kilogramos
cualquier decisión que yo tomaba cuando
tenía 11 años y graba en torno a este
número decisiones en cuanto a elegir si
ponerle pasta de dientes a mi cepillo o
no porque me asustaba el número de
calorías que ésta podría contener
esconder comida en jarrones cajones en
mis bolsillos incluso detrás de mi
cabello contarte que las calorías no
pasaran por mi garganta
cuando piensan en desórdenes
alimenticios que es lo primero que se
les viene a la cabeza
puede que hayan pensado en una mujer que
es extremadamente flaca y que decide
dejar de comer para poder lucir como las
modelos en una revista
pero la realidad es muy diferente y por
eso estoy aquí para poder platicar de la
verdadera cara de estas enfermedades
porque no son una moda del siglo 21 como
muchos lo podrían pensar y tampoco son
un estilo de vida son una enfermedad
son un suicidio
de chiquita tenía un concepto bastante
equivocado sobre lo que es y cómo se
consigue la aceptación propia la primera
vez que me sentí fea tenía 5 años
y creo que aquí nos tenemos que estar
preguntando como sociedad qué es lo que
estamos haciendo para que este tipo de
pensamientos estén en la cabecita de una
niña de cinco años
porque este es mi caso personal pero hay
muchas personas allá afuera que se
sienten como yo me sentía antes
una de las preguntas que más pasaba por
mi cabeza era que se siente
que se siente ser bonita que se siente
verse bonita que se siente sentirse
bonita que se siente verse en un espejo
y no odiar lo que estás viendo
intentar responder estas preguntas e
intentar encajar con las respuestas lo
único que provocó porque a mis 11 años
casi pierdo la vida
hasta la fecha creo que no hay
respuestas para estas preguntas y me
parece completamente absurdo intentar
meter a una caja a un concepto a una
imagen a una idea lo que es la belleza
no sé explicarte lo que es pero puedo
decirte lo que no es y puedo decirte lo
que me habrá gustado saber cuando era
una niña antes de que la frase me siento
gorda se clavara en mi cabeza como una
daga que terminaría con mi autoestima y
casi con mi vida
si el sabor de la belleza son noches
incómodas sin dormir porque tus huesos
se encajan en el colchón de tu cama
perder la mitad de tu cabello tener frío
todo el tiempo
cuando se volvió normal de una niña de
11 años se desvelen por estar
planificando lo que va a comer al día
siguiente o por estar contando calorías
y me da muchísimo miedo hablar de este
tema en público porque es un tema que
tiene bastantes prejuicios
seguramente lo hace para llamar la
atención
ay deja la está jugando a tirarse para
que la levante
dice que se siente gorda y fea porque le
encanta que le digan lo contrario que es
la más guapa de la fiesta
todas estas son respuestas que escuchado
cuando alguien decide abrirse por
completo y platica lo que realmente
piensa sobre sí mismo cuando en realidad
no sabemos qué es lo que le muestra el
espejo a la otra persona y tampoco
sabemos cómo es que su cerebro
interpreta la realidad
estas enfermedades lo que hacen es que
te separan por completo de la realidad
lo que ves en el espejo está
distorsionado porque esta es la forma en
la que tu cerebro funciona
entonces si una persona que padece de un
desorden alimenticio te dice que se
siente gordo o gorda no es porque quiera
llamar la atención o porque esté jugando
a tirarse para que lo levanten
es porque literalmente esto es lo que
viendo el espejo
como que se tiene esta idea de que las
personas que padecen de desórdenes
alimenticios es gente vanidosa que
debería enfocarse en otra cosa y no
solamente en su apariencia física que la
enfermedad
seguramente surge por idolatrar cuerpos
de modelos
qué es un requisito tener que estar
extremadamente bajo peso para poder
padecer una de estas enfermedades cuando
en realidad tu peso no determina la
gravedad de la enfermedad porque el
trastorno es mental y no físico y la
pérdida de peso es solamente una
consecuencia de lo que pasa dentro de tu
cabeza pero no es la causa o un
parámetro para poder decidir si alguien
está enfermo o no por ejemplo alguna vez
que has llamado a alguien anoréxica o
anoréxicos solamente porque es más
delgado de lo normal
este tipo de comentarios lo único que
hacen es contribuir a esta idea de
pensar que para poder padecer de un
trastorno de la alimentación tienes que
estar extremadamente bajo peso pero las
cosas no tienen por qué ser así y no son
así
de hecho contraria a la creencia popular
los desórdenes alimenticios tienen mucho
más que ver con querer tener el control
que con el hecho de querer bajar de peso
hay estudios científicos que demuestran
que hay cierto tipo de individuo a nivel
genético que al ser sometidos a
cotizaciones de estrés son capaces de
desarrollar una de estas enfermedades a
que voy con esto más que las causas sean
sociales como muchos lo podrían pensar
también son biológicas y genéticas
y digo que tienen que ver con control
porque estas enfermedades te hacen creer
que alto poder controlar lo que comes
vas a poder controlar lo que sientes
entonces cualquier preocupación que esté
pasando en tu vida va a ser bloqueada
por este pensamiento
como un mecanismo de defensa a tu
cerebro creado otra realidad en la que
tus únicas preocupaciones son el peso y
la comida porque estas son cosas que tú
puedes controlar
y sin embargo allá afuera en tu vida
real hay cosas que tú no controlas
después de varias sesiones de terapia me
di cuenta de que prefería sentir hambre
a tener que sentir y enfrentar el dolor
que otras situaciones podrían estar
causando en mi vida
y esto es lo duro de estas enfermedades
que te hacen creer que tú estás en
control cuando en realidad quién te ha
estado controlando todo el tiempo es la
enfermedad
y creo que aquí la pregunta que puede
surgir es por qué
porque elegir dejar de comer hasta
llegar al borde de la muerte
y la pregunta es muy dura
pero la respuesta es bien sencilla
no es una decisión
los desórdenes alimenticios no se eligen
pero recuperarse de ello sí lo es
si alguien pudiera preguntarme qué es la
anorexia
yo diría que es un monstruo que se
alimenta de la inseguridad humana
y quiero evitar que ese monstruo llegue
a la vida de más personas
[Música]
cada vez deseamos que haya más
más perfección más delgadez más
tonificación
y sin darnos cuenta todos estos más nos
han llevado a que cada vez sean más las
chiquitas que tienen miedo a engordar
a que cada vez sean más las mujeres que
se someten a cirugías estéticas
a que cada vez sean más las personas que
desarrollan desórdenes alimenticios
a que cada vez sean más las
incomodidades y sacrificios que estamos
dispuestos a aguantar solamente porque a
alguien se le ocurrió decir que esa es
belleza
no será que entre tantos más solamente
nos estamos haciendo menos
porque también hoy estamos deseando que
cada vez haya menos
menos grasa menos calorías menos estrías
menos celulitis menos arrugas menos
canas menos granos no será que por
querer encajar tanto y mantener este
personaje falso y real e inalcanzable
solamente nos estamos haciendo menos a
nosotros mismos
perdiendo nuestra esencia y quien
realmente somos
porque es el google número de la balanza
comienza a disminuir pero también el
número de sonrisas que tendrás el número
de años que vas a vivir y el número de
veces que realmente te vas a sentir
pleno y vivo
en lugar de sumar te estás restando
en lugar de ser más te haces menos
- feliz
menos seguro menos tú
yo te lo quiero preguntar ese es el
sabor de la belleza
un estómago vacío mareos dolor de cabeza
puntos de cirugías estéticas
que tanto le tenemos que restar a
nuestro cuerpo para poder sentirnos
conformes con nosotros mismos
si alguien me hubiera dicho que esta
idea que se le vende a la cabeza de
creer que al alcanzar el peso perfecto
iba a ser feliz era una completa mentira
me habría enfocado mucho más en
disfrutar a mi familia mis amigas
hubiera jugado más con mis muñecas en
lugar de haber pasado parte de mi
infancia encerrada contando calorías
torturándome a mí misma por no encajar
en mis expectativas
porque así se me fueron tres años de mi
vida
viviendo de meta en meta
esperando el día en el que la pluma de
la balanza marcará el peso perfecto para
así poder aceptarme a mí misma
pero esto nunca pasó
y nunca pasó porque estaba intentando
tapar vacíos con cosas externas
y creo que como humanos estamos bien
atorados en eso
creemos que vamos a ser felices hasta
que consigamos tal trabajo cierto nivel
de vida
cuando te vayas a vivir a no sé dónde
cuándo va que solamente dos kilos más y
es fondo mágicamente te vas a sentir
cómodo contigo mismo
no te das cuenta de que estas son puras
mentiras
hay una frase que me encanta de un kart
wii que dice que él desearía que todo el
mundo fuera rico y famoso y cumpliera
todos sus sueños para que se dieran
cuenta de que esa no es la solución
y me encantó porque aunque yo no soy
intervín ni me he hecho así de famosa ni
ha ganado el dinero que él tiene ni me
estoy comparando y tampoco creo
necesario tener que llegar a ese nivel
si pude sentir eso de esa frase cuando
cumplí mis metas o las cosas que según
yo me iban a dar felicidad y
curiosamente cuando las cumplí me sentía
todavía más vacía
y además todo era igual
nada más pensaba menos de la mitad de lo
que hacía antes tenía un espacio
entrevista entre mis piernas mejor
conocido como fire
y había más gente que me volteaba a ver
pero todo era igual
[Música]
y como yo iba a estar equivocada si
estaba convencida de que la felicidad la
iba a alcanzar cuando tuviera el peso
perfecto
y esta idea me comió tanto la cabeza que
no solamente terminé por perder kilos
sino que casi pierdo la vida
y creo que todos en cierto grado hemos
vivido lo mismo
ponlo en el tamaño que quieras
te imaginabas con tu nuevo celular y ya
que lo tienes te da igual empiezas a
perseguir otra cosa
o te imaginabas con tu peinado y con
maquillaje y tu vestido para la boda de
fusión volando
y ese día te da igual estás igual de
frustrado enojado
lloraste por lo mismo que yo era
bastante si te pasa lo mismo
no vas a ser más feliz con todo lo que
se te ocurre que está en el futuro ni
vas a hacer más feliz y recuperarás todo
lo del pasado
renuncia a eso qué crees que está en el
futuro y renuncia a lo que fuiste y vive
y disfruta de la vida el ahora ya acepta
en tu totalidad como estás ahorita
creo que el momento presente es el
concepto más subestimado de la realidad
y es el concepto que más valor nos puede
aportar
el disfrutar del aquí y del ahora hace
que te prendas te conectes te da vida te
da felicidad te hace entender qué es lo
que haces aquí pero se nos va de las
manos porque vivimos creyendo que el
disfrute ya estuvo en el pasado o va a
estar en algún lugar del futuro
y así se te va la vida de meta enmendar
sin darte cuenta de que tu vida está
pasando ahorita
yo ya he renunciado a varias cosas que
creía que quería y ha sido uno de los
temas que más me ha costado trabajo
y si nunca llegó a pesar x cantidad
o si llego a pesar x cantidad pero aún
así no es suficiente
qué liberador sería poder decirme a mí
misma sabes qué victoria como que estás
medio mensual no osa llegar nunca a
hacer lo suficientemente bonita o
delgada creo que ya no la existe juzgue
me el que quiera y alejes el que se
quiere alejar pero prefiero es a tener
que estar cargando con todas esas
presiones
y me imaginaba y me imaginaba que el
liberador sería poder renunciar a esta
estúpida meta hasta que un día logré
hacer las paces
y decir ya la victoria no pasa nada
si no cumple ciertas cosas no pasa nada
y ha sido uno de los debates más duros
que he tenido en mi cabeza porque
entonces llegan otras creencias
será que me rindo muy fácil
será que soy medio hombre
y seguramente va a ver a alguien que me
está escuchando que no esté de acuerdo
conmigo la verdad me tiene muy sin
cuidado pero es lo que yo hice en mi
cabeza para estar mejor y apreciar mi
vida
y eso no quiso decir que deje de ir por
lo que quería
de hecho cuando entendí que no vine al
planeta a pensar platos de comida oa
bajar de peso fue y también cuando
descubrí cuál era mi verdadero propósito
y ha sido cuando más ganas energía
vitalidad transparencias y sonrisas
detenido
y es que cuando leí esta frase de jim
carrey dije claro es que si todo el
mundo pudiera llegar a eso que cree que
lo va a ser feliz de verdad que como se
lo desearía
todos 7 billones de humanos todos
viviendo nuestros sueños y les puedo
firmar y al mes estaríamos partiéndonos
las caras de nuevo porque no
encontraríamos la razón por la cual
sentirnos plenos
que porque el del lado tiene más que
porque ahora quién es otra cosa que
porque ya conseguiste algo pero todavía
no es suficiente
y ya estaríamos frustrados con otra
tontería en miedo con otra tontería y
preocupados por otra tontería
y volteó a ver a jim carrey llegó a ver
es que si este hombre llegó a la luna y
yo apenas le llegue por ahí a una
montaña y sentí exactamente lo mismo que
él
para que la recorremos un poco
porque no creerle
y es que como yo renuncio juraba que
parte de lo que me hacía feliz era ir
por mis metas porque tienes un motor y
tienes un propósito pero cuando te
encuentras muy frustrado con ansiedad
depresión o cualquier emoción que se te
venga a la cabeza que no sé expansiva
pregúntate cómo para qué fregados estoy
persiguiendo eso
y no es que no es que esté en contra de
tener metas propósitos o sueños todo lo
contrario pero es saber poder distinguir
si lo que quieres alcanzar lo quieres
tener para llenar vacíos o lo estás
haciendo por amor porque ahí es en donde
cambia todo el panorama
y puede que esté iniciando baja
pero como como suelto
perdónate y renuncia a eso que crees que
te va a ser feliz
y por qué digo perdona te porque créeme
que es un proceso bien duro por todo lo
que socialmente cargamos
porque neta tanto me lo dije tanto me
convenció mi cabeza de que había que
conseguir eso
tanto hice tanto sacrifiqué tanto
aguante que pensar que ya no lo que
podría ya no tenerlo duele
como que te sientes un perdedor
y hablando de eso la frase los ganadores
no renuncian al contrario
qué perdedora me sentido yo cuando
estaba persiguiendo todo eso que creía
que me iba a ser feliz y ni siquiera me
sentía plena
qué perdedora me sentido yo cuando lo
tenía todo y yo estaba suicidándose
y al contrario
qué ganadora qué maravilla poder
disfrutar de la y de la hora y ser de
verdad plena y agradecerlo
hazte un favor y mírate a ti mismo
pero no solamente te veas mírate déjame
hacer tu espejo porque eres mucho más
que un número en la balanza el tamaño de
tu casa o cualquier meta retorcida que
sea que estés persiguiendo
durante tanto tiempo estuve deseando
poder cambiar mi físico para así poder
aceptarme a mí misma sin darme cuenta de
que lo que tenía que cambiar era mi
mentalidad
durante tanto tiempo estuve deseando
ocupar menos espacio
y ahora no me importa ocupar más de él
hoy vine ya llena todo el auditorio
muchísimas gracias por haberme escuchado
[Aplausos]
[Música]